shellie starts off this hour in
tennessee hi Shelly
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up well and my husband I have a
disagreement on what we need to do with
our budgets and we kind of reached a new
season of life he retired from the Air
Force after 30 years and we moved to
Tennessee and we have a new mortgage and
we don't have any debt except for a
mortgage but and a couple of years ago
we stopped paying into our RA because we
wanted to pay off another house that we
owned at the time so we got that paid
off but we really were living on just
his pension right now and we don't have
we don't really have any kind of a
savings plan implemented but he doesn't
seem to think that we need to be saving
anything because he has you know a
salary every month from his retirement
and but I keep thinking and we took like
a 30-year loan on our house but I what
we wanted to pay it in 15 but we're not
paying anything extra on it so I wanted
to pay extra on the house still put
money into savings and retirement that
he is not really wanting to do that
right now so I just wanted your advice
on what you thought we should do well
obviously we teach people to invest into
retirement and to get their homes paid
off we don't teach anyone to keep a
mortgage their whole life and we don't
teach people to not save money and hope
that they can live on their pension kind
of crazy actually
so yeah you definitely need to be
investing how old are you guys I'm he's
55 and I'm 53 he's 55 55 yes I heard and
he doesn't work no why not right now
well that's a long story he's tried to
get several jobs and he hasn't been
offered some jobs that we just didn't
think they were right for our family
situation so he was getting impatient
and he just decided that we should just
choose a place where we wanted to live
and then bill
there and then he would get a job that
he hasn't really looks for a job in the
area because she's building an airplane
and he wants to work on that which is
very expensive and so he builds an
airplane well I don't think so either
but he seemed to think that he does but
it's about a hundred thousand dollars
good lord
yeah I know that's what I think too
but he's not really listening to me well
I'm not sure I can help you I think you
guys need marriage counseling this guy's
off the rails he's 55 years old he quit
work another airplane in your gun he's
building 100th I know I'm 59 I've worked
40 years and I hadn't quit work by the
way you're broke you owe me money right
what well I don't think we're broke I
mean we do have about 57,000 in our
checking account and then we have almost
200,000 your retirement account and we
own a lot and you're building $100,000
airplane one third of your net worth is
going to be in an air well yeah I'm not
building it like well you're involved in
it this is part of your life you're
attached to this mess so I know that's
why I said you need marriage counseling
I don't I don't I think this I think
there's a whole lot of other stuff going
on here
I don't know what he's having his
midlife crisis late or what's going on
but you know you don't build $100,000
airplane when your total net worth is
200 grand
that doesn't make sense at all and and
you don't quit work at 55 when you've
only got $200,000 saved and you've still
got a 30-year mortgage you are not done
you're not done you need to create some
income and you need to go back to
investing and get this house paid off
and when your millionaire we can talk
about buying an airplane for $100,000
but not until you're millionaires and
you're not and it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense at all so you know
again I can't make someone behave stupid
is not illegal
so you and you can't either for that
matter but you're gonna you're gonna
suffer the consequences if you stand by
and just say well it's what he wants to
do I can't do anything about it
you're attached to it you're gonna
you're gonna you know as a ship takes on
water you're gonna be the one getting
fit your feet wet and so you really do
need to seek some marriage counseling
because you've wandered off to another
city bought a house all these things are
going on this guy's that he's
disconnected this is a dangerous place
I hope hope a marriage counselor can
help y'all